[Music]
taro reads sexual assault allegation
against her former boss Joe Biden has
not been proven likely it never will be
it happened an awfully long time ago she
says but newly discovered evidence from
almost 30 years ago offers surprising
support for Reed's claim this came
almost out of nowhere a clip from Larry
King Live the old 9:00 p.m. show on CNN
features a call from a woman Reed tells
reporters his her mother watch this
San Luis Obispo California hello yes
hello I'm wondering what a staffer would
to do besides go to the press in
Washington
my daughter has just left there after
working for a prominent senator and
could not get through with her problems
at all and the only thing she could have
done was go to the press and she chose
not to do it out of respect for him or
she had a story to tell but out of
respect for the person she worked for
she didn't tell her ha that's that's
fascinating rich McHugh is a longtime
reporter who's been on this story and a
lot of big stories he joins us tonight
rich thanks so much for coming on
tonight so we just lay out the facts of
as we know them and the allegations if
you would sure so Tara Reid worked for
Joe Biden in 1992 and 93 for about eight
months she says that at the time she she
faced some sexual harassment from from
him unwanted touching and she had
complained about it and it fell on deaf
ears and so she said she went and filed
a complaint you know outside of the his
office in some senatorial office that
would they would handle these things
around that same time she says she was
asked to deliver him a gym bag in US in
one of the Senate buildings and she
brought it to him and she says it was a
you know it was a warm spring day hot
spring day and she said that she that he
attacked her in a corridor it wasn't a
private private office or anything but
tacked her and assault
are sexually assaulted her and she she
came for with an allegation last year
last April she told a local paper she'd
been telling people about this she told
people at the time she told her mother
she told a friend she told her brother
and she may have told some others and so
now she came out last year and told part
of her story to a local paper in
California and a few weeks ago I believe
it was she came out with her full
allegation article by Ryan grim and
podcast like Katie help her and since
then you know everybody's been examining
the veracity of her claims let me just
clarify something there there all of
this is kind of a mishmash when you talk
about sexual assault sexual harassment
you're not she's not suggesting that he
said something vulgar to her she's
saying that he grabbed her genitals is
that is that right that's correct that's
correct okay so that puts it in a
different category from a lot of the
stories like this that we hear really
quickly tell us about this call to Larry
King where did that clip come from so
she had told me about this I said you
know in in the process of reporting this
she came and said I was trying to you're
always trying to figure out how to how
do if you're investigating how to how to
kill a story and if you can kill it then
you don't read it and I was always
trying to track down this this clip and
without working at CNN I couldn't go in
there today the enterprising PhD student
a woman sent a note to myself and to
Ryan grim saying hey I think I found it
and I think Ryan was was he probably
responded to her quicker than I did and
so we got to this moment this afternoon
where we both realized that there was
this this video was was found and you
know he published it we actually talked
but he published a story and the rest is
history that's amazing I mean as a
decade before YouTube so it's not so
easy to find cable news clips from 1993
right rich McHugh thank you for that
Update I appreciate good to see you
tonight my pleasure thanks for having